cette semaine l'éclaireur du gâtinais se
met au vert la moitié de l'hebdomadaire
est consacrée à l'environnement et aux
initiatives locales dans ce numéro on
trouve des sujets très concrets comme
par exemple l'interdiction des
pesticides dans les jardins pour les
particuliers depuis peu les le tri
sélectif évidemment qui concerne tout le
monde et puis par exemple la voiture
électrique on en parle beaucoup on a
décidé ça collectivement parce que
toutes les semaines on parle de sujets
traitant à de l'écologie du
développement durable et on s'est dit
que on voulait mettre en valeur un petit
peu ce qui a été fait sur le territoire
et on a trouvé que faire une sorte de
compilation de de tout ce qu'on avait pu
faire compilation mes sujets réactualisé
c'était une bonne idée est ce que cette
formule éphémère va séduire dans ce bar
tabac il ne manque que l'éclaireur sur
le porte journal problèmes
d'approvisionnement le jour de notre
tournage au grand dam des fidèles
lecteurs j'ai toujours acheté
l'éclaireur mes parents aussi
c'est le seul journal qui donne vraiment
les dernières nouvelles de la région je
ne passe à ma femme je me passais ma
belle-soeur chez l'éclaireur chez nous
avec ce numéro spécial les cinq
journalistes tentent de se renouveler et
toujours entretenir cette proximité avec
leurs lecteurs plus le journal est
proche du quotidien des gens plus il a
des chances de continuer à plaire à
apporter quelque chose c'est sûr qu'il
faut faire face au renouveau à nouvelle
va internet notamment
mais on est confiant la presse
hebdomadaire souffre moins que les
autres types de presse en france et je
crois que c'est parce qu'on parle des
gens et qu'on
et qu'on sait leur apporter leur
apprendre des choses
lancée au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale l'éclaireur est aujourd'hui
impactés par le numérique et le
changement des habitudes des jeunes
lecteurs limiter la baisse des ventes
papier c'est le défi de la rédaction
chaque semaine